[Music]
[Applause]
hello everybody good morning and welcome
to the Academy of Motion Picture Arts
and Sciences
I'm Cheryl Boone Isaacs president of the
Academy I want to thank everyone for
joining us for these exciting
announcements celebrating the heroes of
moviemaking and lucky for us we have a
super hero here with us today ladies and
gentlemen the very talented Chris
Hemsworth thank you very much good
morning everyone let's get right to it
the 2013 nominees for Best Performance
by an actor in a supporting role are
barkhad Abdi in captain Phillips
Bradley Cooper in American hustle
Michael Fassbender in 12 years a slave
Jonah Hill in the wolf of Wall Street
and Jared Leto in Dallas buyers club
Chris thank you for Best Performance by
an actress in a supporting role the
nominees are Sully Hawkins in blue
Jasmine Jennifer Lawrence in American
hustle Lupita and yong-go in 12 years a
slave Julia Roberts in August Osage
County and June Squibb in Nebraska for
Best Original Song the nominees are
alone yet not alone from alone yet not
alone
music by Bruce Broughton lyric by Dennis
Speigel happy from Despicable Me 2 music
and lyric by Pharrell Williams let it go
from frozen music and lyric by Kristen
anderson-lopez and Robert Lopez the moon
song from her music by Karen O
by Karen Oh and Spike Jonze an ordinary
love from mandela long walk to freedom
music by Paul Hewson Dave Evans Adam
Clayton and Larry Mullen you may know
them better as u2 lyric by Paul Hewson
for adapted screenplay the nominees are
Richard Linklater Julie Delpy and Ethan
Hawke four before midnight
Billy Ray for Captain Phillips Steve
Coogan and Jeff Pope for Philomena John
Ridley for 12 years a slave and turns
winter for the wolf of Wall Street for
Best Original Screenplay the nominees
are Eric Warren singer and David
O'Russell for American hustle Woody
Allen for blue Jasmine Craig Morton and
Melissa Wallach for Dallas buyers club
Spike Jones for her and Bob Nelson for
Nebraska for best animated feature film
we are pleased to nominate the Croods
chris sanders kirk demicco and Christine
Belson
Despicable Me 2 Chris Rea know Pierre
cofán and Chris melody and REE Ernest
and Celestine Benjamin Renner and vidya
Brunner frozen chris buck jennifer lee
and Peter Delvecchio and the wind rises
hayao miyazaki and Toshio Suzuki for
Best Documentary Feature the nominees
are the act of killing Joshua
Oppenheimer and Cena be orga Sorenson
cutie and the boxer
Zachary Hines Earling and Lydia Dean
Pilcher dirty wars Richard Rowley and
Jeremy Scahill the square Jehan new Jim
and Kareem
and 20 feet from stardom nominees to be
determined for Best Foreign Language
Film the nominees are from Belgium the
broken circle breakdown from Italy the
great beauty from Denmark the hunt from
Cambodia the missing picture and from
Palestine Omar for best achievement in
directing David O'Russell for American
hustle Alfonso Cuaron for gravity
Alexander Payne for Nebraska Steve
McQueen for 12 years of slave and Martin
Scorsese for the wolf of Wall Street the
best performance by an actress in a
leading role the nominees are Amy Adams
in American hustle Cate Blanchett in
blue Jasmine Sandra Bullock in gravity
Judi Dench in Philomena and Meryl Streep
and August Osage County for Best
Performance by an actor in a leading
role the nominees are Christian Bale in
American hustle Bruce Dern in Nebraska
Leonardo DiCaprio in the wolf of Wall
Street
Chua tell Ejiofor and 12 years of slave
and Matthew McConaughey and Dallas
buyers club and finally we are pleased
to announce that the film selected as
the Best Picture nominees for 2013 are
American hustle Charles Roven Richard
suckle Megan Ellison and Jonathan Gordon
producers captain Phillips Scott Rudin
Dana Brunetti and Michael De Luca
producers Dallas buyers club
Robbie Brenner and Rachel winter
producers gravity alfonso cuarón and
David Heyman
produces her Megan Ellison sparked Jones
and Vincent Lando produces Nebraska
Albert burger and Ron Yorkshire produces
Philomena Gabriel Tanner Steve Coogan
and Tracy seawood produces 12 years a
slave Brad Pitt Dede Gardner Jeremy
kleiner Steve McQueen and Anthony
catechist produces and the wolf of Wall
Street nominees to be determined for the
complete list of all the nominations
please visit Oscar calm and join us
Sunday night March 2nd to celebrate
these incredible artists and films at
the Oscars see you then
[Applause]
[Music]